Axl stay in Italy gets off to a chaotic
start he keeps getting lost despite the
cars sat-nav and italian drivers can be
quite a challenge axel has come to the
southern Italian city of Naples equipped
with a football
he finds plenty of people to play with
Axl meets up with the three candidates
for today's euromaxx world cup test in a
local park they're all keen football
fans okay now you did some warm up now
it's time for our world cup spirit test
okay we met some Brazilians for the
first round and they scored 19 points
out of a maximum of twenty seven do you
think you can beat this yes we will be
this the first round is tractus corner
okay everyone has three shots and
there's the ball go for it
Oh
they only managed two goals
okay so not really like what I expected
from like Italian football fanatics yes
there is a terrible results but we can
do better ok the next round is the quiz
we want to know how much you know about
the italian national team okay how often
did italy first question how often did
italy win the world cup four times the
four times in 1934 in Italian damn a
1938 in France 1982 in Spain and 2006 in
Germany congratulations brilliant okay
that's another three points for you
second question which italian national
player holds the record for playing the
most matches fabrica Navarro yes yes
fabio cannavaro correct again great so
another three points for you last
question how far did Italy get in the
last world cup 2010 we were eliminated
in the group stage where the new zealand
slovakia and paraguay i was there for
you being eliminated in the group stage
it was very very bad okay the last round
of a game is know your opponent okay so
I hear five mass of english national
players there you see three shirts of
the english national team of three
players and you have to match these
faces with the shirts okay so take the
mosque time starts now okay so match
them okay and this one oh you already
finished so you use you feel safe you
think you think that's really correct it
was quite simple this this game we know
very well the this player if you're
really right we see when the standings
turn around okay so please turn around
that's correct that's correct hey that's
another nine points for you yeah okay so
we we have a final score you beat the
brazilians yeah but but only sorry we
always a beat brazil okay but but only
with one point yes but it's a great
powerful points
Oh
later Axl meets up with his new pals to
watch the match against england the
Italian fans are jubilant when the game
ends with a 2-1 victory for easily
I can't imagine a more extreme Italy
experience lost in traffic here in
Napoli then the Italian fans beat the
brazilian girls in the euro max World
Cup spirit test and then this match my
next stop will be in England and I'm
really curious how the atmosphere will
be there after the national team lost
its first match in the world cup
you